la comunidad internacional responde a un
desesperado llamado de ayuda el
presidente Turco recepta Jeep erdogan
declaró a 10 ciudades impactadas por el
terremoto como zonas de desastre decretó
el estado de emergencia por tres meses y
confirmó Este martes que al menos 70
países han ofrecido sumarse a los
esfuerzos de búsqueda y rescate unicef
se preocupa por la posibilidad de miles
de niños muertos mientras la OMS estima
que el terremoto pudo haber afectado a
unas 23 millones de personas
estamos especialmente preocupados por
aquellas áreas donde no podemos obtener
información estamos tratando de trazar
los daños para entender Dónde debemos
concentrar nuestra atención
la Unión Europea activó su mecanismo de
protección civil y ha movilizado más de
10 equipos de búsqueda y rescate
incluyendo un sistema satelital de mapeo
de emergencia Países Bajos y Rumanía han
enviado y tiendas de campaña mientras
que rescatistas italianos llegaron a la
zona y equipos de perros de búsqueda
alemanes también se unen a los esfuerzos
Grecia y Suecia que mantienen tensas
relaciones con ankara también se han
ofrecido a ayudar china aseguró que
proporcionará más de 5.9 millones de
dólares en ayuda humanitaria y Rusia
informó que sus primeros equipos de
rescate ya se encuentran en la zona del
desastre Estados Unidos prometió ayudar
a su Aliado de la otan y brindar ayuda
humanitaria a las ong en Siria
el presidente ha autorizado una
respuesta inmediata de Estados Unidos
estamos en el proceso de desplegar
equipos adicionales incluidos dos
equipos de búsqueda y rescate urbanos de
79 personas Para apoyar los esfuerzos de
búsqueda y rescate de Turquía y ayudar a
abordar las necesidades de todos los que
han resultado heridos o desplazados por
el terremoto
en Siria la situación se hace más
difícil al completarse 12 años de guerra
civil cientos de familias siguen
atrapadas entre los escombros de los
edificios derrumbados mientras que
varios países se despliegan por las
zonas más afectadas